a visit to the michelin-starred
restaurant Aphrodite in the South of
France promises a high quality culinary
experience
but the first course is quick to turn up
a surprise meal worms and crickets are
all part of the alternative menu which
these guests have willingly ordered love
them or it doesn't put me off we should
be open to new face when they have that
owners when I first heard of it I
thought hmm you just can't stomach that
but then I thought what the heck I'll
try it the restaurant Denise with a
taste for creepy crawlies belongs to
French chef David for the 42 year old is
known for his experimental streak his
main passion is molecular cooking but
three years ago on the search for new
flavor combinations he discovered the
world of insects junkie BYOD source when
he told you I was traveling abroad where
insects depending on the continent in
the region I everyday ingredients in
cooking horny solid eagle was a success
and some larger ones even considered
delicacies showing off when I came back
to France I felt it was time to risk
something new that's what our guests
expect to available meekly off the
five-course alternative menu will set
you back fifty nine euros David foul
uses complementary flavors to unlock the
nutty aroma of mealworms and popcorn
like crickets
joy peak ladies are sanctity I could
have tried to hide the flavor of the
insects with other ingredients but I
like to do things differently the worm
featured in the apple moose should be a
tasty treat for me it's important that
each dish tell a story I might shock
people with that sometimes but the
provocation is meant in a nice way salar
de pau gasol rocky edible insects are
commonplace in many regions around the
world but in Europe bugs on the menu are
a no-go it's a risk this top chef is
willing to take the elderly 12 bullets
ladies will I lose the star because of
the insects will find out in 2014 when
the new Michelin Guide comes out but i
think the guide recognizes all cuisines
even those with insects I'm not flippant
about this ingredient and I think chefs
can prepare anything as long as it's
edible you'd was of up to target the
company micronutrient make this possible
for four based in Toulouse they make all
sorts of tasty morsels using insects
exclusively in their dried form were
sold over the internet for between 12
euros and fifty euros per portion and
they also offer handcrafted pralines and
macaroons
safe like oh you're founded the company
in 2011 there's a monkey do finicky I
wanted to set up a company that was
sustainable environmentally and also
socially I really un recommended the
consumption of edible insects but that
in Europe there weren't any companies
that could supply such things I simply
got to it and embraced the adventure on
sit down I said I want you but first the
30 year old had to research how to farm
edible insects with the help of a team
of biologists and agricultural
economists his experiments now also
include African and Asian insects for
now European crickets make up most of
the production seven crickets are
supposed to contain as much protein as
100 grams of steak micro nutria has
mealworms on offer this year the company
is planning to produce a ton of these
insects mmm school and confession we
develop products using powdered insects
our goal is to produce food that
consumers are already familiar with
cannot easily did you do consume me
eating a whole insect the way David feau
prepares it takes a bit more effort for
some guests liguria question the taste
is subtle car cuts very crunchy I like
that and it goes well with the other
ingredients Falls intention isn't merely
to provoke his guests he wants to change
the general attitude towards food
Kabbalah feature we're preparing for the
future mineral in a few decades will
probably have to accept that while we
may not need to eat insects exclusively
we will have to integrate them into our
meals also we should start preparing
Europeans for that now d-mat know
for now though it's early days and a
michelin-starred insect menu may still
only be possible for the most
adventurous of gourmets
you